>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Fenella France:
Good morning, everyone.
I want to welcome
you to today's Topics
in Preservation Series
talk by Elham Bakhtary,
"Tracking the Provenance of
Printing in Afghanistan."
Elham was the 2016, '17
CLIR Mellon fellow here
in the Preservation Research
and Testing Division.
And this is [inaudible]
here from CLIR with us.
And this is a program, a
doctoral fellowship program
that we are just
delighted to be involved in.
It means we get to
really see people,
up-and-coming people
with new research.
And it means that they get to
use any of the instrumentation
in our lab to look at original
materials within the library.
So it's been for us all
a fascinating journey
as we learn more
about collections
that we didn't know about.
So I'm going to hand over
to Elham to talk about some
of his research today.
Thank you.
>> Elham Bakhtary: Oh, man.
Yeah, sorry about that.
I just want to give some
brief acknowledgment.
I want to thank the
Council on Library
and Information Resources for
making all of this possible.
And giving me the
opportunity to work
with the Preservation
Research and Testing Division
of the Library of Congress.
And I want to extend a warm
thank you to everyone in PRTD.
Not every single member of
PRTD worked on this project,
but everyone offered
their assistance.
And so I want to give a
special thank you to Fenella
for approving and
overseeing this project.
Also to Amanda Jones,
Megan Wilson
and Chris Bolser [assumed
spellings] for being
with me every step of
the way in this project.
And also to Jasmine
Hahn in conservation
for giving constant advice.
And also Stephanie Stillo
[assumed spelling] as well
from the Rosenwald Collection
for being a great advisor
as well through some tough
times and doubtful moments.
But thank you for helping
me get through this as well.
And also just to recognize
the Library of Congress
as an incredible institution
that helps with some
of these challenging issues.
Like the history of
print in Afghanistan.
Which began in the reign of
this fearsome looking gentlemen.
This is Amir Shayr Ali Khan.
This came from an issue
of a London paper called
"The Graphic" in
November of 1878,
immediately after the
British invaded Afghanistan
to dethrone Amir Shayr Ali Khan.
They feared that he was creating
an alliance with the Russians.
And that the Russians
in the future could potentially
use Afghanistan as a base
from which to attack
British India.
And so they invaded him
and dethroned him in 1878.
He died actually trying to
escape to Russia in the process.
When they invaded Afghanistan,
the British shelled
the Amir's fortress
where the first printing
press was housed.
And the printing house
caught on fire and all
of its materials were burned.
And it was subsequently
looted as well.
So we actually have
very, very few materials
from this time period left.
But thanks to the
diligence of the Library
of Congress we have some of
these materials available to us.
And I know this doesn't
look like a very long list.
But this is actually a
really large percentage
of the materials that are known
to exist from this time period.
The first work of "Hujjat-i
qaviyah dar ibtal-i aqayid-i
Vahhabiyah-i ghaviyah" means
Conclusive Argument Invalidating
the Misleading Wahabbi Creed.
This was a heresiography
targeting Wahabbis.
"Shams al-Nahar,"
Afghanistan's first newspaper.
"Shams al-Nahar" meaning
"The Morning Sun."
The library has two original
issues of "Shams al-Nahar."
And "Tuhfat al-Ulama," which
means a "Gift to the Ulama."
Now the first item,
as the title suggests,
is a heresiography
condemning Wahabbis.
The second two I would describe
as mirrors for subjects.
Meaning that they instruct
subjects, including the ulama
on how to behave
as good Muslims.
And in this talk I
will suggest that,
although the Amir's court
initially used propaganda
to attack the Wahabbis,
it was the Wahabbis
that inspired these
latter forms of propaganda
in both form and substance.
And through my research with
PRTD, I will also propose
that the amir of Kabul not only
shared a common market of ideas
with the Wahabbis, but
also a common market
of printing materials
with them as well.
So I want to give a brief
survey of the history
of print during Amir
Shayr Ali Kahn's reign.
According to colonial
records in 1869,
he starts using a
lithographic press explicitly
for the purpose of
printing stamps.
On the left you have an
image of a lithographic press
from around this time period.
And on the right you
have an image of a stamp
of Amir Shayr Ali Kahn.
That image in the
middle is of lion.
That was the symbol of Amir
Shayr Ali Kahn's reign.
His name Shayr meaning lion.
That he imported the press to
print stamps is quite telling
in that it shows the press
was not originally intended
for propaganda.
It's not until two years later
that we actually have
works of propaganda.
So why did he begin to use
the press for propaganda?
To answer that we look
at the two oldest works,
both of which were religious
polemics targeting Wahabbis.
Now, they were called Wahabbis,
but their actual name was
the Tariqah-i-Muhammadiyah,
which means the Muhammadan way.
They were a militant
revivalist movement
in British India founded
in the 19, in the 1820s.
And you can think of them
as a Muslim counterpart
to the Protestant
movement in Europe.
They believed that Muslims
should not rely on saints
to be mediators between
them and God.
They believed Muslims
should access holy
scriptures themselves.
Read them for themselves.
And interpret it themselves.
And like Protestants they were
enthusiastic about using print.
If you think everyone should
read the scriptures themselves,
there needs to be a means by
which they can get access.
So in 1824, they established a
printing press from Calcutta.
And then shortly thereafter they
established printing presses
in other cities such as Delhi.
Lucknow. Lahore.
And Bhopal.
They printed pamphlets that
were easy to understand
in simplified language.
And in those pamphlets
they would explain
to people how traditional
clerics,
traditional ulama
had prevented Muslims
from understanding true Islam.
Which could only be found
in the holy scriptures.
This is an image of a later
Wahabbi publication housed here
at the Library of Congress.
We actually had to order this
from the field office
in Islamabad.
But it came relatively quick.
I mean, faster than the
stuff I order off of Amazon.
But this author,
Shah Abd al-Aziz,
he was not actually a
member of the Wahabbis.
He was sort of a
forerunner to them.
But they revered his work.
And this image just kind
of gives you an idea
of how the works look.
Very simple.
Simple design.
But the writing is very elegant.
You see three different types
of scripts there
Nasta'liq, Naskh and Thuluth.
So this kind of gives
you an idea
of how their other
publications looked.
Now, in 1826, not too long
after they established the
printing press, the founders
of the movement go to
what is today the Punjab
to fight the Sikhs, who
had been Muslim there,
from certain practices.
Like the public declaration
of prayer.
And also the consumption
of beef.
And at first the people,
at first the Wahabbis were
welcomed by the locals.
But then they started
to have conversations
with them about religion.
And found that their
ideas were very unorthodox
and very untraditional.
And one of those individuals
was the Akhund of Swat.
This is his tomb, which
is frequented today
by many pilgrims.
This, the Akhund of Swat was
an illiterate saintly figure
who had hundreds of
thousands of followers
in India and Afghanistan.
He was so influential
that the British referred
to him as a pope.
And he has some conversations
with these Wahabbis.
And he figures out how
different their outlook is.
And he declares the
Wahabbis to be infidels.
And so he basically
expels them from the areas
that are under his influence.
They go and find refuge
with the religious rival
or spiritual rival, if you will,
of the Akhund, the
Moolla of Kotal.
And this individual had a
large following himself,
but not as great at
the Akhund of Swat.
And this Moolla listens
to the Wahabbis
and he actually agrees
with their views.
Even though he was a
saintly figure himself,
he actually came to, came
around to accepting
most of their doctrines.
And when Akhund finds this out,
he declares the Moolla
to be a Wahabbi too.
And to make matters more
complicated for himself,
the Moolla also embraced
Protestant missionaries.
Such as T.P. Hughes, who was
a very important missionary
in the Pashto speaking areas
of what is today Pakistan.
He let's these missionaries,
these Protestant missionaries
preach to the people
and circulate translated
copies of the Bible.
And what happens then is
that Christian converts become
labelled Wahabbis as well.
And part of the reason is
that people didn't really know
they were Christians a lot
of time.
Because, when they would come
to the villages, they would try
to talk about Islam strictly
using the Quran and Hadith.
But in this part of the
world, there are more sources
about what Islam could be.
There could be oral traditions.
Saintly figures and so forth.
And so, when you only use Quran
and Hadith, they were like, oh,
these guys are Wahabbis.
And they, sometimes they
would never even find
out that they were actually
Christians because of that.
So sometime before 1871,
the Akhund requests
from Amir Shayr Ali Kahn
and his ulama a refutation
of the beliefs of the Wahabbis.
Now, why ask Amir
Shayr Ali Kahn?
Well, the Akhund was
illiterate for one.
But there were already
refutations written
in India about this group.
Massive refutations
by eminent scholars
like [inaudible] of Delhi.
But traditionally it was the
prerogative of an Islamic ruler
to deal with heretics.
Even if he would commission
ulama to write heresiographies
about them, it was still his
responsibility to do that
and also to punish the heretics.
The problem is, is that
India's ruled by the British.
They're not Muslims.
And, therefore, they can't
really give these types
of polemics any legitimacy.
But the Amir of Kabul, the
Amir of Afghanistan could.
And he was the closest
independent Islamic ruler
to India at the time.
And it also helped that
he had a printing press.
And I believe that because the
Wahabbis were very effective
in using the press and
perhaps the Akhund recognized
that manuscripts and even
oral traditions were not going
to be enough to counter the
effects of Wahabbi publications.
It was time to fight fire with
fire, print against print.
And so in 1871, the Kabul court,
the court of Afghanistan
issues two refutations
of Wahabbi doctrine.
The one on the left is the one
I mentioned "Hujjat-i qaviyah."
And the one on the right is
"Shihab-i Saqib,"
"The Piercing Flame."
The one on the left, which
is housed here at the Library
of Congress, was
authored by Abd al-Rahman.
This is a very scholarly work.
It is in very sophisticated
Persian and Arabic.
The one on the right is
actually authored by the Amir.
And it's not scholarly at all.
And the Amir admits
this in the work.
And he explains why.
He says "In this tract I have
not entered into a discussion
of many Islamic sciences.
I believe the ulama in every
country have already crafted
scholarly responses
to this unbelief.
But because those writings
include scholarly terminology,
the masses cannot
understand them.
Hence, it is not the clerics
that are falling into the claws
of these owls, rather the
hunt of these enslavers is
after the mice who are ignorant.
This is a teeth-shattering
response to the infidels
that no one has yet to give,
which will render the infidels
without the strength
and ability to speak."
So, yeah, you can't really
talk without your teeth.
So, and that kind
of gives you an idea
of how flowery this language is.
And what kind of
language Persian actually,
it goes in all kinds
of twists and turns.
But this was actually
very simplified.
This, the kind of Persian used
in "Shihab-i Saqib" was
much more simplified
than the one used in "Hujjat."
And, in general, this was
one of the traits that
"Shihab-i Saqib" shared
with Wahabbi literature.
The focus was on using the Quran
and Hadith, not using auxiliary
or supplementary texts
from the Islamic sciences.
Those materials were
not really used at all.
At the top I have some of
the works that were cited
in "Hujjat," the scholarly work.
Those are just a fraction.
I mean, there are many,
many works from different
time periods.
Different schools of thought.
And "Shihab-i Saqib" only
two works are mentioned.
And they're not really
even cited.
They're just kind like
the Amir is saying,
I'm not really making
all this up.
If you don't believe me, you
can find something similar
in these works, if you want.
Otherwise he just uses
the Quran and Hadith,
which was very common of
the Wahabbi literature.
They didn't use auxiliary
materials either.
And it's written for
society at large.
It's in this accessible
language.
The Amir states in "Shihab-i
Saqib," "For the honor
of the strong Muhammad in
religion, I have desired
to present in some
plain words, in simple,
fluent Persian the
beliefs and opinions held
by these unfortunate people."
So that was his opinion
of what simple Persian is.
But, nonetheless, yes, I mean,
relative to the time period,
it was actually quite
accessible.
After these two heresiographies
are published, Amir decides
to produce more propaganda.
But not to attack the Wahabbis.
But to attack Afghanistan's
own ulama,
Afghanistan's own
religious clerics.
He actually never
mentions the Wahabbis again
after these publications.
And I suggest that, although
the first two Kabul publications
went after the Wahabbis
viciously, the Amir learned
from the Wahabbis just how
effective print propaganda could
be in changing the
minds of society
in challenging recalcitrant
clerics.
The Wahabbis had really
shaken the authority
of traditional ulama in India.
They had drawn tens of
thousands of followers away
from eminent ulama,
including seminary.
Some prominent scholars
even became members
of the tariqa became
Wahabbis themselves.
And the tariqa also
inspired the Deoband
and Ahl-i Hadith movements,
which are today major schools
of thought in India,
Pakistan and Afghanistan.
Now, why is the Amir
so interested
in challenging his
own country's ulama?
Well, historically
in Afghanistan the
ulama were central
to legitimizing the
power of the Amir.
And also recruiting
volunteers for his army,
especially during civil
wars and foreign invasions.
And the Amir was trying to
centralize the government
of Afghanistan, primarily
through a central, modern army.
The problem was that a lot
of ulama were financially
independent of the Amir.
They didn't need his patronage.
They already had other
sources of patronage.
Tribal chieftains.
Local rulers.
Even the Amir's brothers who are
rival claimants to the throne.
And, moreover, these
reforms threatened
to disenfranchise
the ulama's patrons
of their traditional military
authority and revenue.
Historically these chieftains
and local rulers provided
military levies to the Amir
in exchange for revenue
and autonomy.
But the Amir was looking to
circumvent them and reduce them
to pensionaries, to
state pensionaries.
And so the ulama, almost
like representatives,
articulated opposition
to the Amir.
But instead of saying,
hey, you know,
you're disenfranchising
our patrons,
they crafted a religious
argument.
And said these reforms
you're trying
to institute have no
precedence in Islam.
They're innovations and,
therefore, they are violations
of Islamic law of the sharia.
Therefore, the Amir had
been in need of a way
to respond to that argument.
But it's only after the Wahabbi
debates he begins printing
materials that address
that opposition.
One of those pieces
of propaganda is
Afghanistan's first newspaper,
"Shams al-Nahar."
This was more like a gazette.
It was first printed in
1873, and it contained news
from around the world.
Now, the Amir didn't actually
have correspondence, you know,
in Africa and Europe
and these other places.
What he did was he took
stories from British-Indian
and even British newspapers.
And he would have those,
this is a table just kind
of giving you an idea of
some of the newspapers used.
There were many other
newspapers used.
But you can see they're
from all over South Asia.
Karachi. Lahore.
Bombay. Calcutta.
Very distant parts.
And in very, in different
languages as well.
Persian, Urdu and English
were the main ones.
He had a translation bureau.
They would translate these
materials into Persian
if they weren't already
into Persian.
And there was a pretty, I mean,
there was all kinds
of different topics.
A lot of them focused
on conflicts in Europe.
Civil wars in Spain.
Franco-Prussian War.
Also topics about science.
But the most important
pieces in "Shams al-Nahar"
for my research were
these think pieces
that could be reflections
on news items.
Or they were printed speeches of
the Amir or his chief secretary.
And sometimes they were
even original articles.
And all of these think
pieces had a common argument.
That the Amir's subjects needed
to take the example
of other countries.
And pursue knowledge
and show loyalty
to their ruler, to the Amir.
And they also voiced
opposition to the clerics
that opposed the Amir's reforms.
And in 1875, a book was
published addressing this
very issue.
This is "Tuhfat al-Ulama," the
book that addresses this issue,
housed here at the
Library of Congress.
You can see it's pretty beat up.
These lithographs have witnessed
quite a bit of war going back
to the second Anglo-Afghan
War in 1878.
This work was authored by the
Amir and his chief secretary.
And the way this work
opposes the ulama
of Afghanistan is
almost identical
to how the Wahabbis opposed
the ulama of British India.
For one, I mean,
it's in print just
like Wahabbi literature was.
But also it was an
accessible language.
It emphasized the holy
scriptures, the Quran and Hadith
to the exclusion of
supplementary materials
from the Islamic sciences.
And it casted the ulama of
Afghanistan as being misleading,
holding people back from
the true message of Islam.
The same way the Wahabbis
characterized the ulama
of India.
And this raised the
question for me,
if the Amir's court was
getting discursive ideas,
rhetorical ideas
from the Wahabbis.
Were they also getting
printing materials from some
of the same places Wahabbis
were getting materials?
Or just simply where did the
Amir get his printing materials
and his printing press from?
This is something
that scholarship has
not really addressed.
Very few scholars have
even touched upon the reign
of Amir Shayr Ali Kahn.
I've even seen in some books
on the history of Afghanistan,
they just don't even
mention him.
Even though, I mean, he's there
for about two decades involved
in Afghanistan's history.
It's a very difficult
period to talk about
and not for no reason.
Because, again, most
of the materials
from that time period
were destroyed
when the British
invaded the country.
Also British colonial records
have a lot of information
about Amir Shayr
Ali Kahn's reign.
But they don't have
much information
about the printing press.
When I was doing research
in India, I found an item
in the catalog saying it
was about the newspaper.
And I was so excited.
And I got the item,
and I opened it up.
And it was one sentence.
The Amir wants to
start a newspaper.
So the British didn't,
weren't really interested
in where the Amir was getting
his printing materials from.
They were really only concerned
where he was getting his weapons
and those type of materials.
So we don't have a lot of info.
We can gather bits and pieces
from the lithographs themselves
by looking at the colophons.
And in the colophons we see
that there was a
clear Iranian element.
That there was definitely
Iranians involved
in the production
of these works.
Two of the names,
Muhammad Sadiq Tabrizi
and Mirza Bayza Khan Shirazi.
The [inaudible] onomastics,
Tabrizi, Shirazi,
note where their
city of origin was.
So we know they came from Iran.
And the fact that they were
from Iran was not surprising.
Because Iran had long
established printing there,
both topography and lithography,
early in the 19th century.
And they had learned
it from the Russians.
They had sent individuals from
Tabriz initially and then later
from Shiraz to go there
and learn topography
and lithography.
It's not clear how they
came to Afghanistan.
But since there was no printing
press in Afghanistan prior
to Amir Shayr Ali Kahn's reign,
we can deduce there weren't
people in Afghanistan
who had adequate knowledge
on how to work a press.
And, therefore, the Amir
solicited the services
of these men to work the press
and possibly import
printing materials as well.
These were the only clues I
got from the text themselves
about the possible
origin of the press.
But instead of answering the
question concerning the origin
of the press and
printing materials,
it just created more
confusion for me.
Iranians got lithography
from the Russian.
But Indians got it
from the British.
The Afghans have Iranian staff,
but they're getting their
newspapers from India.
So where do the Afghans
get their printing press
and printing materials from?
Well, thanks to the
clear Library
of Congress Mellon Fellowship I
got to work with PRTD in trying
to answer this question.
And what we did was
analyze the paper used
in the Afghan lithographs to
see if we could identify point
of origin or points of
origin for that paper.
And we compared the paper in the
Afghan prints with paper used
in prints from neighboring
areas.
So we first assessed the paper
used in the Afghan prints.
And we saw that there was
a combination of laid paper
and machine-made paper.
And we used multispectral
imaging and x-ray fluorescence
to see if we could
establish the characteristics
of both the Afghan
and foreign paper.
And to see if there
were any matches.
XRF didn't help much
because each source had a
unique reading.
There were some patterns,
such as zinc peaks,
were characteristic of Amir
Shayr Ali Kahn's lithographs
in comparison to those
produced outside of Afghanistan.
As well as those produced inside
Afghanistan after his reign.
But none of these patterns could
give us a definitive indication
of where the paper came from.
Multispectral imaging was more
helpful in that it allowed us
to see watermarks
on the laid paper
without too much interference
from the ink and chain lines.
And so just going
to go through some
of these watermarks with you.
The first here is C. Millington.
This appears to be referring
to the English paper
company Millington and Sons,
which was managed by
Charles Samuel Millington
and Charles Leschallas
Millington.
This watermark is found in a few
materials from around the world.
Including England.
India. Japan.
New Zealand.
And, of course, Afghanistan.
Next one is of a lion and
a unicorn with a shield
and a cross in the center.
I believe this is,
was the counter mark
to the C. Millington watermark.
And you can see that the font
of the years is identical.
The next one is Pro
Bono Publico.
It says universal foolscap
at the bottom there.
This was also found in a
few works around the world.
Including India.
Indonesia.
And possibly among the Armenian
community of Iran and Jaffa.
This one, Leschallas.
I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that right.
This one, as you can
see, is a shield.
Leschallas across the front.
Horses head at the top.
I believe this one also came
from Millington and Sons.
Because the middle name of one
of the sons was Charles
Leschallas Millington.
There were other
people with this name,
but that's my inference is
that this also came
from that company.
And the use of the crescent
moons is quite interesting.
Because crescent moons
were commonly used
by other European mills to
produce paper explicitly
for the Islamic world.
And thus we see this
watermark mostly in the,
used in the Muslim
parts of India.
Like Kashmir and Hyderabad.
And the last one is
Dorling and Gregory.
This one doesn't seem to have
been used very commonly outside
of the British.
I only saw one instance
of it being used outside
of British India in Ethiopia.
But it was being used by
British Indian officials.
So it doesn't seem like
this one had a particularly
wide distribution.
And we only had one
case of this being used
in the Afghan lithographs
as well.
Now, all of these
mills or the companies
that owned them were
based in London.
And so this gives us a pretty
good indication that the press
and printing materials came
from British India or at least
by way of British India.
So that helped answer
the question
of where the Amir got his
printing materials from.
But a couple of these watermarks
have even more significance.
The C. Millington watermark
was found in a work printed
by Reverend T.P.
Hughes in British India.
And he was one of
the missionaries
that worked very closely
with the Moolla of Kotal,
the Akhund's rival
and accused Wahabbi.
And the Pro Bono Publico
universal foolscap, I found this
in a book authored by
the son and successor
of the Moolla of Kotal.
So it's interesting
that at least part
of the group the
[inaudible] referred
to as Wahabbis were probably
procuring printing materials
from the same distributors
the Amir was using.
And at a minimum it shows that,
although the heresiographies
implied a sharp divide
between the Amir
and the Wahabbis,
in actuality not only did
they share discursive methods.
But also sources of
printing materials as well.
So reminds us not to take
polemical works at face value.
And to see how they can often be
produced within a common market
of both ideas and print.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Has anyone, okay,
so the question is,
is there any research existing,
scholarship on the importation
of materials originating
in Britain to India?
>> Paper.
>> Elham Bakhtary:
Paper, paper specifically.
So it's interesting, I mean,
there were newspapers printed
in the 19th century
just about paper.
And they would discuss
the mills of England.
That's where I got
the information
about these watermarks
from mostly.
And they would talk about
how much the rates were.
And where they were
landing in British India.
But at that point the
trail kind of gets lost.
We don't really know what
happens with the paper itself,
who it was sold to specifically.
There's also the issue of paper
being produced in India itself.
Especially starting in 1870.
The British actually, the
British raj passed a law stating
that all paper used in
official tasks needs
to use domestically
produced paper.
And they had a huge campaign to
have paper produced in prisons.
I don't know if they really
followed up with their act.
Because when I was looking
at, you know, colonial records
from the 1870s, I mean,
they still were using paper
produced mostly from Britain.
So I'm not sure how
far that went.
But based on those
newspapers that were produced
in the 19th century, there's
not a very strong indication
of what happened to the paper
once it got to India; right?
It was mostly just
tracking the rates
and how much they sold for.
So there aren't really
any, not to my knowledge,
there aren't really any
sources, primary or secondary,
about where the paper ended up.
Especially machine made paper.
I mean, because there was
so many different producers
in Europe at the time,
it's very chaotic.
And they didn't have
watermarks either.
And so that kind of made our
task quite difficult as well.
>> Does the design of the
polemical lithographs,
is that sort of specific
to a manuscript tradition?
Or was it sort of reaching out
to something that was familiar
in terms of sort of a
visual cue or culture?
>> Elham Bakhtary: I would
say it was mostly in line
with the manuscript tradition.
It's interesting though, yeah, I
would say it was mostly in line.
Like there's things
that, there are changes
that don't take place yet.
I mean, because I've
thought about this.
So you don't really see
punctuation marks yet.
And this was one of the reasons
why lithography was so popular
in the Islamic world is
that because it wouldn't be
so different from the
manuscript tradition.
People would be able to keep
their jobs as calligraphers
and scribes and what have you.
What's interesting,
though, about this one is,
"Hujjat" on the left, is that
it doesn't use a colophon.
And I still don't know why.
It just has an imprint
on the front.
Whereas, "Shihab-i Saqib" does.
Another interesting thing is,
this is not exactly
related to your question.
But I'll just bring it
up since we're talking
about the colophons
and everything.
The editor for the one on the
left, for the scholarly one.
His last name was Shirazi,
which would have been
a good indication
that he was Shia from Iran.
And this author is Sunni.
The Shirazi is left out of
his name in the imprint,
but it's not in the
Amir's publication.
And so it kind of highlights
perhaps the different mentality
that the Amir, mentalities
the Amir had.
Or different mentality
the Amir had in contrast
to his own ulama
at the time, yeah.
And this individual,
Mulla Abd al-Rahman,
he did not author
anything else besides this.
So "Tuhfat al-Ulama,"
which criticized ulama,
he had nothing to do with that.
And he probably was not very
fond of it either, yeah, yeah.
But it's interesting because
there is its own system
of punctation that I'm not sure
how far, how much it goes back
into the history
of the manuscript.
But I had to figure it out.
Because they would use things
like the letter [inaudible]
in Persian over certain words.
And then I finally realized
that that's an indication
that it's a foreign word.
You know, they would
do things like that.
They would have the first word
of the next page at the bottom.
That was a standard
process carried
over from the manuscript
tradition.
Which is funny because that
helped people when they,
they used codex style bindings.
And that helped making sure
that the binding was accurate.
They don't use that kind of
binding for most of these works.
The one on the left, they did.
But for the rest they didn't.
But they still kept that system
of putting the first word
of the next page at the bottom.
So, yeah.
>> Yeah, it's very interesting
that they would have
imported that much paper.
So I'm interested in local and
whether there's any evidence
that local paper making
was done [inaudible]
like the mills would establish
local mills and so [inaudible]?
>> Elham Bakhtary: Yeah.
So the question is did any of
these mills based in London
or any of these companies have
mills set up in other locations
in South Asia where they
could produce this paper
with the same watermarks?
I think it's a possibility.
Based on my research I was not
given any indication of that.
But there were a few mills.
I think India at
the time, in 1870,
only had something
like five mills.
And I don't have much
information about those mills.
And it seems like they were
making machine made paper
as well.
Not the laid paper
with watermarks.
But it's possible.
I wouldn't rule it out.
There's also, there was paper
being made in Iran as well.
But it's so confusing because
in a country like Iran,
they are making their own paper.
But they're still importing
the majority of their paper.
And they're importing
it from places
like Russia and British India.
And so in a particular work, you
don't even actually really know
where the paper came from.
Was this Iranian paper?
Was this British Indian paper?
Was this Russian paper?
Again, you know, once the
paper is, arrives, it's like,
it's just lost as to where
the origins were and so forth.
So it's just kind
of hard to kind
of figure out all these things.
I wouldn't rule that out though.
I wouldn't rule that out.
I think that still
is a possibility.
We would just need more
research in that respect.
But because the watermarks,
they were not altered at all.
Like, you know, they would still
say London or what have you.
That, to me that suggests
they had actually come
from British India, produced
in, excuse me, in Britain
and imported to British India.
But we still have to keep that
possibility open as well, yeah.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah.
>> And you see that paper
appear in archival records,
different principalities.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Elham Bakhtary: Right.
Right. And this particular
work, "Tuhfat al-Ulama,"
it had some really, I mean, it
used some really weird paper.
It was very thick.
It reminded me of some of
the paper samples I saw
in Dard Hunter's work
on paper made in India.
And, I mean, one of the
questions we had was,
were the Afghans possibly
making their own paper?
And, you know, I
don't want to jump
into a crazy conspiracy
theory for you guys just yet.
But this work was
printed in 1875.
This was the same year that
relations between the Amir
of Afghanistan and
the British soured.
Like, they really went south.
The British really
started having suspicions
that the Amir was entering
into an alliance with Russia.
The Amir starts talking
a lot about jihad.
And the British are afraid
that he's trying to, you know,
prepare his own people for a
possible war with the British.
And so I sometimes,
it seems kind of odd
that the paper would
just be so different
from all the other ones that
we had from earlier years.
And I feel, I suspect
that there's a possibility
that the British started
restricting the Amir's access
to paper.
And he had to start getting
paper from some other sources.
So that's a possibility as well
too that we have to keep open.
Just can't say definitively,
yeah.
Any other questions.
You can ask general questions,
too, about the Wahabbis.
I mean, I know that that's
a lot of information.
Hopefully I explained it in a
way that was easy to comprehend.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, yeah.
>> Fenella France: So just
please, if you can join
with me in thanking Elham.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Elham Bakhtary:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.